スティーブ:こんにちは 夏美さん
夏美:こんにちは
スティーブ:あのね今日はね
スティーブ:伊藤夏美さんと
インタビューなんですよ
スティーブ:今日は言葉の
勉強だけじゃなくて
スティーブ:言葉と文化と
色んなその形でね
スティーブ:色んな…僕の日本語
大分忘れましたけれども
スティーブ:色んな側面から
スティーブ:文化と言葉について
話をしたいと思うんですが
スティーブ:まず夏美さん
スティーブ:自己紹介みたいなもの
お願いできますか
夏美:はい 分かりました
夏美:みなさん こんにちは
伊藤夏美です
夏美:今あのLingQの
ポッドキャスト
夏美:日本語の見てる方は
知ってるかと思うんですけど
夏美:そこでホストもしています
夏美:いつもは自分の
スタートアップ
夏美:クリーンテックの
スタートアップなんですけれども
夏美:それをチームと一緒に
東京ベースで経営しています
夏美:主には水の泡の技術で化学薬品とか
そういったものではなくて洗浄する
夏美:そういったソリューションで
あのSDGsのあの何ですか
夏美:1つの貢献できる技術として
今着目されているので
夏美:それの日本展開と海外展開
っていうのをやってたりします はい
スティーブ:なかなか面白い 面白そうですね
夏美:そうですね
スティーブ:あのそういうね
若い人たちが
スティーブ:そういう
スタートアップをやったりですね
スティーブ:新しいビジネスを作ったり
僕は非常にもう尊敬してる
スティーブ:羨ましいと思います
夏美:ありがとうございます
スティーブ:本当にもう僕は日本に
住んでた頃はね 誰とでもですね
スティーブ:その大きい大企業に勤めて
その死ぬまでこの決まったパターンでね
スティーブ:動くしかなかったんですけれども
夏美:年功序列みたいな
スティーブ:今の世の中はそうじゃないね
年功序列ですね
スティーブ:今はそうじゃないんですよね
夏美:そうですね
スティーブ:で非常に面白いと思うのは
スティーブ:夏美さんはそういう…
そういうビジネスを作るんじゃなくて
スティーブ:色んな意味で非常に
独立的な活動というか
スティーブ:若い時に日本
もちろん日本生まれ日本育て けれども
スティーブ:あとは台湾に4年住んでて
それからまた日本に戻ってまた
スティーブ:米国
アメリカ合衆国へ行って
スティーブ:非常にその国際的な
そういう経験があると思うんですけれども
スティーブ:それはどういう風に
夏美さんに その何ですか
スティーブ:ものの見方ですね
考え方に影響があったんですか
夏美:絶対的に海外に出たことに
よって考え方っていうのは
夏美:もっと視野が広がったと
思いますね確実に
夏美:やっぱりあの
ずっと日本にいたら
夏美:その 何でしょう
日本人だから みんなと同じようなこと
夏美:それこそ年功序列しないけど
夏美:高校行ったらじゃあ大学行って
大学行ったらじゃあ企業に勤めてみたいな
夏美:それが当たり前のレールで
夏美:当たり前のことを
みんなやるのが当たり前でしょ みたいな
夏美:結構日本って
その何ですか あの
夏美:みんなと同じカテゴリーに
みんなと同じレベルを付けたりとかって
夏美:やっぱそういうことが結構
カルチャー文化的にもやっぱり大きいと思うんで
夏美:そういう部分で逆に
いや 自分はこうしたいっていう
夏美:その自分はこうしたいとか
自分はこういう風にやりたいとか
夏美:その自分の自我をしっかり持つ
ていうマインドセットっていうのは
夏美:海外に行ってから
すごいあの培(つちか)われた
夏美:周りのそこで出会った友達とか
今も仲良い友達も凄いたくさんいますし
夏美:そういう色んな価値観を
持ってる人たちに出会えた
夏美:っていうのが1番
大きかったかなと思います
スティーブ:そうですね 確かに
今の若い日本人もそういう方が多いですよね
スティーブ:自分のその何か
ビジネス作ったりとか
スティーブ:どこか外国行って
何かその独自のねその…
スティーブ:仕事を独立して新しい面白いことを
やろうと思う人が結構多いわけですよ
スティーブ:しかしそれはね何も
日本だけじゃなくて
スティーブ:日本にいて日本の…
みんなと同じようなことをやりたくないから
スティーブ:もう少し広く見たいと
スティーブ:しかし同じことも
スティーブ:もうカナダであろうが
アメリカであろうがね
スティーブ:同じこと
もう言えるわけですよ
スティーブ:だから世界出れば台湾なら台湾
いやもうドイツならドイツですね
スティーブ:その違った国の人たちも
スティーブ:非常に我々と
そんなに違わないんだと
スティーブ:そのあれですよ
そのどこそこの国じゃなくて
スティーブ:その人は何を考えてるか
どういう風にこの人と組んで何ができるかと
スティーブ:そういうその何ですか
国民っていうか そういうことじゃなくて
スティーブ:1人の人間として
これから何を想像するかっていうかね
スティーブ:それが非常に大事だと
思うんですよ どうなんですか
夏美:そうですね
なんかやっぱり私も
夏美:今まで色んなところに居て
夏美:色んな友達とかがいるから
よく聞かれるのは
夏美:結局何人だったらいいのとか
夏美:そのどこ出身の人が
いいとか あのその
夏美:どんな人種が
いいとかっていう風に
夏美:カテゴライズして質問してくる人も
いたりするんですけど
夏美:でもやっぱり最終的には
夏美:やっぱりその日本出身だからとか
カナダ出身だからとか そういうのじゃなくて
夏美:やっぱりその 個人で
その人がどういう人間なのか
夏美:その日本出身だからって
言ってみんながみんなその
夏美:いわゆるステレオタイプな
すごくポライトで礼儀正しくて静かでっていう
夏美:みんながみんなそうじゃないと思うんで
やっぱりそのスティーブさん言ったように
夏美:まあ みんな違うから
夏美:その人がどういう人なのか
っていうのが分かったら
夏美:もっと面白いんじゃ
ないかなとは思います
スティーブ:そうですねそれで
言葉の勉強においてもですね
スティーブ:僕もいつも
言うんだけども
スティーブ:そのじゃあ僕は
その英語を話してるそのカナダ人という
スティーブ:その立場から
言葉を勉強するんじゃなくて
スティーブ:その元々の
その僕はもう関係ない訳ですよ
スティーブ:私はもう日本語を勉強するなら
僕は日本人になりたい
スティーブ:フランス語を勉強するなら
もうフランス人になりたいとか
スティーブ:そういう文化をですね
超えた形で
スティーブ:自分がその対象の言葉の
その人たちの仲間に入りたいと
スティーブ:そういう精神が
非常に大事だと思うんですよ
スティーブ:フレキシブルに
考えないといけないんですよ
スティーブ:そしたら
その文化を集中するが
スティーブ:それなりに その言葉も
早く勉強できるわけですよね
夏美:それは…それは凄い分かります
スティーブ:そういう事だと思うんですね
夏美:私もあの19歳で
初めてアメリカの大学に行って
夏美:その本当にみんな英語しか喋らない
っていう環境に飛び込んだんですけど
夏美:その時あの日本人私だけで
夏美:誰も他日本語喋れる人が
誰もいなかったんですよ
夏美:日本語のカルチャー分かる人も
誰もいないしっていう
夏美:その時に初めて
夏美:やっぱり日本語しか分からないからみたいな
だから英語を学びたいとかじゃなくて
夏美:本当にあのアメリカ人みたいに
なりたいと思ってだから1回…
スティーブ:そうですよね
夏美:日本人だからなんか…
みたいなのを取っ払って
夏美:アメリカ人…
彼らみたいに喋りたいと思って
スティーブ:そうですね僕も
そういう経験も何回もありましたよね
スティーブ:私はカナダ人だからと
誰も気にしない訳ですよ
スティーブ:あの夏美さんが
アメリカでね
スティーブ:あなた日本人
だからっていう事
スティーブ:誰も気にしないですよ
夏美:気にしなかったですね
スティーブ:もうあなたは誰か…誰かのフレンドだ
フレンドかどうかでそれだけですよね
スティーブ:何人であろうがね
もう関係ないんですよね
スティーブ:そうですね
あの夏美さんのLingQのポッドキャスト
スティーブ:僕も何回も聞きましたよね
夏美:ありがとうございます
スティーブ:非常にテーマが
非常にホットで面白いですよね
スティーブ:でやはり言葉の勉強も
ですねやはり面白いその内容
スティーブ:面白いテーマが
大事なんですよね
スティーブ:だから普通のもう教科書みたいな
つまらないような内容じゃなくて
スティーブ:非常にそのデートする…
その ねぇ男性女性とか
スティーブ:そういうようなテーマは
誰も興味ありますからね
スティーブ:それは非常に…
スティーブ:そしてそれの
ポッドキャストか
スティーブ:あとはトランススクリプトが
あるからテキストがあるから
スティーブ:そのLingQで
勉強すればですね
スティーブ:やはり面白い
そのポッドキャスト聞いてから
スティーブ:その後それを読んだり
知らない単語もフレーズをセーブして勉強して
スティーブ:非常にやはり うちのLingQの
メンバーのためになると思いますよ
スティーブ:本当にありがとうございます そういう事
夏美:ありがとうございます
夏美:いやでもやっぱりそのLingQの
本当のコンセプト的にも
夏美:やっぱり私も
やっぱり色々言語を勉強してみて
夏美:そのテキストでなんか
これを学べみたいな
夏美:これをグラマーで学んだら
ベースが付くから分かるでしょみたいな
夏美:そういうのだとやっぱり興味がないから
その…長続きしないんですよねなんか
夏美:やっぱり自分の興味があるコンテンツ
スティーブ:そうですね
夏美:私の友達とか
日本に住んでる外国人の友達とか
夏美:やっぱりその
デーティングとか
夏美:じゃあ日本人の子と
付き合うにはどうしたらいいとか
夏美:はたして自分は
日本でモテるのかとか
夏美:どういう風に
言ったらいいのかとか
夏美:そういうのはやっぱり
みんな興味があったりするんで
夏美:じゃそういうリアルに話してる会話をじゃあ
スティーブ:ありますよ
夏美:そのコンテンツで
聞いてみるとか
夏美:そっちの方が興味があって
夏美:多分知りたいと思うんで覚えると思うし
実際使ってみたりすると思うし
スティーブ:そう そうですよね
スティーブ:そしてやはり僕も
あの思い出しますけれども
スティーブ:日本に僕住んでた頃はですね
商売を中心にね
スティーブ:だから相手がその
お客さんだとか
スティーブ:だからそれなりの
環境があるわけでしょ
スティーブ:それだけの
その内容があるけれども
スティーブ:僕の息子ですね
スティーブ:マークが日本の
そのアイスホッケーチームですね
スティーブ:プロアイスホッケー選手を
やってですね日光アイスバックスで
スティーブ:彼がその自分のチームメイトと
飲みに行った時
スティーブ:僕もまあ2・3回も
一緒に行きましたけども
スティーブ:全然違うんですよ
雰囲気がね
スティーブ:僕とそのビジネスの話し…
だって飲みに行ってもですね
スティーブ:関係が違うんですよね
スティーブ:私は売りたい
相手がお客さん
スティーブ:やはり…その何ですか
スティーブ:使う言葉とか
態度的にもですね
スティーブ:ある程度のその
神経使うんですよね
スティーブ:そのお客さんだからっていう事でね
夏美:そうですね
スティーブ:でそれに比べて若い人たちが
ホッケーのチームメイトがもう軽くこう
スティーブ:飲みに行った時に
その会話はまた違うんですよ
スティーブ:だからどんな雰囲気でも
それなりのまた雰囲気がある訳ですよ
スティーブ:それをあの味わうことが
非常に大事と思うんですよ
スティーブ:だからあの
夏美さんのLingQポッドキャストも
スティーブ:まぁこのアイスホッケーの
チームメイトと違うけれども
スティーブ:非常にその軽くて
楽しくて非常に良いと思います
夏美:ありがとうございます
夏美:今まであの元ラグビー選手の方
にも出てもらったりとか
夏美:あとはヨガの先生やってるとか
自分でカフェやってるとか
夏美:日本語の先生もいますし
私の普通のただの友達とか
夏美:あとはフリーランスで
色々活動してますとか
夏美:なんか色んな子を呼んで
まぁカジュアルに話してるんで そうですね その
夏美:一般的に本当の日本人がどうやって会話するの
日本語ってやっぱりその
夏美:スティーブさん言ったみたいに
ビジネスのミーティングとか
夏美:あとすっごいやっぱり敬語で
まあ相手を敬うような言い方で
夏美:日常会話でそれを友達に言うかって
言われたら絶対言わないんで
スティーブ:そうですよね
夏美:喋り方も変わってくるし
っていうので
スティーブ:それも文化なんですよ それも文化
夏美:そうですね
スティーブ:文化は
能とか歌舞伎じゃないですよ
スティーブ:文化は全て文化ですよ
スティーブ:夏美さんはこれから
なんか新しいことは勉強したいんですか？
スティーブ:なんか中国語と英語
以外には何か考えてますか
夏美:今興味があるのは
スペイン語とフランス語ですね
スティーブ:なるほどね
スティーブ:あの あれですよ
挑戦してください
スティーブ:スペイン語はですね
スティーブ:多分日本人にとっては
1番覚えやすいんじゃないですか
スティーブ:発音が その母音が
日本語と全く変わらないですから
スティーブ:発音は
スティーブ:フランス語は1つ難しいと思うんですけど
夏美:フランス語はすごい発音難しいなと思って
夏美:舌巻いたりするのが難しいと…
スティーブ:そうです
スティーブ:発音とね理解…
その何ですか
スティーブ:あの聞く時の理解力が
あれが難しいけれども
スティーブ:しかし これは慣れの
問題ですから
スティーブ:それなりの勉強したいなら
その動機っていうかね
スティーブ:それが1番大切ですから
スティーブ:そのスペイン語とフランス語
どちらがあの夏美さんとして
スティーブ:もっと勉強したいか興味みがあるとか
夏美:それだったら…スペイン語ですね
夏美:やっぱりあの…
スペイン語喋ってる人たちって
夏美:凄い人口として
世界で1番多いじゃないですか
スティーブ:そうです たしかに
夏美:だから私凄い色んな
新しい国とか行くの好きなんで
夏美:英語の国だったら
全然問題ないけど
夏美:やっぱりあの
メキシコとかまあもっと…
夏美:あの南アメリカとか
そっちの方色んな国があるんで
夏美:そういうところでも…
何だろやっぱり言語が喋れた方が
夏美:そのローカルの
本当の体験ができたり
夏美:もっと楽しい経験が
できると思うんで
夏美:そのなんか観光客で行くんじゃなくて
行くんだったら
夏美:本当にもっと色んな経験が
できるような状態で行きたいなと思ってるんで
夏美:スペイン語を喋りたいなとは思います
スティーブ:そうですね
スティーブ:頑張ってください
スティーブ:これからLingQで
スペイン語を
スティーブ:やってください
夏美: 頑張ります
スティーブ:とにかく今日はあの楽しい話
できて ありがとうございます
スティーブ:そしてこのLingQのポッドキャスト
続けてやってくれて大変感謝しております
スティーブ:そして またその次の時は
スティーブ:スペイン語で話ししましょう
夏美:スペイン語⁈頑張ります
スティーブ:次の時
OK じゃあどうも
スティーブ:じゃあ失礼します
夏美:バイバイ ありがとうございます